ça ne fait jamais ça c'est ce qu'on
appelle écrire la diapositive ils le montrent
beaucoup à la télé ça va coincer votre
arme tirez et lâchez tirez et lâchez donc
faites ça pour moi encore belle maintenant
accédez correctement à notre magazine  poignardez-le dans
le râtelier à fusils le toboggan comme un homme des cavernes /
perceuse k obtenez un bon goutte à goutte alignez vos
vues sur la cible regardez vos pouces
cristal ils sont un peu farfelus Chris
tu es libre là tu vas maintenant tu le répares
très bien  sur la commande de combat tirez un
coup prêt combattez sur la commande de combat
tirez deux coups prêt vous devez attendre
jusqu'à ce que je dise combattez ou je vous retirerai